Speaker 1: Hey, this is really interesting.
New Hampshire Republican Senate candidate Don
Bolduc last month said the election was stolen by
Joe Biden and Trump won. Yesterday on Fox News,
Bolduc was confronted with his own comments and he
denounced them and he said, You know what? I did
my research. Biden won. Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: Basically against Morse, the more
establishment Republican candidate, because they
were basically saying that you're so extreme
that they think that you're more beatable.
And one of the things that Maggie Hassan,
the Senate incumbent, will say is
that you are an election denier, that.
Speaker 3: You deny that President Biden won the.
Speaker 4: 2020 election. And there is this.
Speaker 3: From August 14th, when
you had a debate, which here.
Speaker 5: I signed a letter with 120 other
generals and admirals saying that Trump won
the election. And dammit, I stand by my.
Speaker 4: Wow. Do you stand by that today?
Speaker 1: No.
Speaker 5: So, you know, we we we,
you know, live and learn. Right. And I've done a
lot of research on this. And I've spent the past
couple of weeks talking to Granite Staters all
over the state from, you know, every party and
I have come to the conclusion and I want to be
definitive on this. The election was not stolen,
was there? Oh, God. Yes. Is that a concern of
Granite Staters all over the state? Yes, there
is. Is there a responsibility for public servants
in elected positions to ensure that our citizens
have faith in their voting system? Yes. But
elections have consequences. And unfortunately,
President Biden is the legitimate
president of this country and he
is ruining it. Along with Maggie Hassan.
Speaker 1: So, listen, is it good that Bolduc is
willing to say this? Well, yeah, it's good because
some people on Fox News might hear it. Does this
represent his real and true personal belief? I
have no idea, because the real interpretation of
what Bolduc is doing here is he realized that with
New Hampshire voters insisting that the election
was stolen and Trump actually won isn't helping
him. That's fundamentally what this is about.
And so it's about political expediency. My guess
is Bolduc never believed that Trump actually won.
I think he was saying it because he thought it
would help him. And then when it became clear
it wasn't helping him, he stopped saying it. But
it's still nice for Fox News viewers to hear that